foreign
if I were to tell you rain world has the
most complex ecosystem of any game you
might go what because rain world doesn't
seem particularly Advanced it's a 2D
pixel art game where you play as a weird
slug how complicated could its world
really be while there are other games
with fancier graphics and denser lore
Reign world's unique system of
procedurally generated animation and
complex AI come together to simulate the
feeling of a living ecosystem better
than almost any other game I've played
so for this entry into the archive we'll
uncover the fascinating intricacies of
rain world's pixelated biosphere now
let's become part of this virtual food
chain
foreign
world begins with a cut scene showing a
family of weasel-like creatures called
slug cats struggling to survive a storm
breaks out and a young slug cat the
protagonist falls into the drains below
and awakens in a new and unknown
environment
the game then quite literally drops you
into the ecosystem it's disorienting at
first but pretty quickly you learn how
to live like a slug cat in this world
you are small but crafty able to catch
and feed on small creatures like the
fluttering bat flies
but from your first steps the animation
feels different and that's because it is
like most of the creatures you'll meet
in Rain world the slug cat is
procedurally animated meaning its
animation is determined in real time
through code interacting with the game's
environment since the dawn of Animation
pretty much the only way to get a
creature to move has been to hand
animated moving frame by frame but in
Rain World a creature's motion happens
organically within a set of
predetermined parameters creating
movement that feels uncannily
spontaneous
one mind-blowing example of rain world's
complexity are the lizards these enemies
move with procedural animation just like
the slug cat able to run across flat
ground crawl through tunnels and climb
up poles but they take this to another
level with their AI when one lizard
catches you it will try to drag you back
to its den but if another lizard passes
by its AI will cause it to try and
snatch you for itself which can give you
a dynamic opportunity to escape but
that's just scratching the surface of
lizard complexity each lizard also has
their own simulated personality based on
six unique modifiers that determine how
they interact with each other and on top
of that there are nine different types
of lizards in this game all with their
own distinctive abilities and behaviors
for example yellow lizards have long
antennae that allow them to communicate
with each other meaning their AIS work
together to surround the slug cat or cut
them off using the terrain white lizards
can camouflage with whatever pixels are
behind them in their environment so they
hunt by staying completely still until
the slug cat gets close then lash out
and try to pull the slug cat in with
their long tongues
cyan lizards can use bursts of energy to
pull off incredible jumps that when
paired with their AI leads to some of
the most hilariously unpredictable
movement patterns I've ever seen in a
video game
and there's another hidden system that
can go completely unnoticed by the
majority of players if you consistently
feed a lizard their preferred food they
will eventually become your Ally and
start following you around and will even
get into fights with other lizards that
try to eat you it's a surprisingly
detailed system that shows just how
meticulous rain world is when it comes
to its ecosystem
in the next region of the game four
larger predators called vultures
sometimes swoop in from above on
nightmarish Wings vultures will also
climb after the player and squeeze
through gaps their procedural animation
particularly uncanny while vultures are
intimidating as scavengers they can be
scared off if you stand your ground and
throw Spears at them which will
sometimes cause them to drop their masks
seemingly implying these Predators
aren't entirely organic if you hold a
vulture's mask in front of you most
creatures will run from the player's
slug cat instinctually scared off by
your resemblance to a top predator
Giant Orange centipedes also lurk in the
recesses of this ruined landscape if one
catches you they'll admit a lethal
electric shock like clockwork the
centipedes move with a general sense of
coordination indeed much of rain world's
ecosystem follows a similar pattern with
the titular rain that comes every so
often marking the end of each cycle when
the rain falls all life forms must
hibernate or drown in the downpour soon
the player settles into these cycles and
feels like a small part of a larger
biosphere
following the dripping pipes deeper
underground the slug cat plummets into a
kingdom of waterlogged tunnels known as
the drainage system swarms of leeches
writhe in these half-flooded Chambers
when the slug head is close the leeches
AI causes them to go into a frenzy
following the slug cat's movements and
waiting for the chance to latch on if
the slow cat slips their best chance of
survival is getting back above the water
and shaking them off for unlike the
leeches of today these bloodsuckers
aren't just parasitic they're predatory
leech swarms coordinate to drag prey
down Into the Depths drowning whatever
unfortunate creature they can latch onto
yet one species uses this to their
advantage squid cadas are
cuttlefish-like creatures that flutter
Along on four small Wings to feed squid
cadas have learned to fish for Leeches
by diving into the water and letting one
latch on the squid cata then flies off
with the careless parasite feeding on
them a safe distance away it's a
remarkably Dynamic behavior and one you
can go the whole game without seeing if
you move too quickly
the drainage system eventually washes
into the garbage wastes an entire
ecosystem of decaying junk yet there is
life here in the form of the inquisitive
garbage worms these long stretchy
creatures are something of a nuisance
with their Curious nature causing them
to steal Spears from the slow cat when
given the opportunity often snatching
them directly from the slow cat's hand
when no Spears are in reach gorbage
worms will stick their heads into the
grime and start sucking up matter
suggesting that they feed on inorganic
material while normally passive make a
garbage worm angry and they will go on
the attack flinging the slug cat around
with their heads or even holding the
Unlucky creature underwater in an
attempt to drown them groups of garbage
worms will even coordinate their attacks
their eyes turning red to indicate their
hostility
in the murkiest depths of the garbage
wastes a true nightmare stirs hauling
themselves up from the depths the
menacing brother longlegs probes for
their next meal though made of a large
bulbous Mass with several ravenous
tentacles extending from their core the
brother longlegs are flexible enough to
squeeze through tunnels unable to hear
or see they rely entirely on touch to
find prey and win a brother longlegs
latches on they refuse to let go
eventually wearing the creature out and
drawing them into an unseen mouth where
these monsters came from is a mystery
that can only be solved by venturing
deeper into this hostile environment
the garbage wastes empty into the flood
waters of the shoreline here a drowned
Empire of crumbling monoliths greets the
slug cat it's impressive the sense of
melancholy the pixels on screen can
produce
blue leeches swim in these Waters a
coastal variant that is larger and more
aggressive than their red counterparts
able to pull the slug cat under in
seconds if you manage to avoid the
leeches there's plenty of other dangers
here even the plants of the shoreline
are carnivorous with the terrifying
monster kelp ready to swallow you whole
if you get too close sensitive to
movement monster kelp is difficult to
sneak past in pursuing the slug cat
these plants will twist and contort in
unexpected ways and feel particularly
alive due to their adaptable Behavior
behind the scenes of the monster Kelps
AI each strand of kelp Moves In
accordance with the slug cat's position
instead of following a predetermined
path when paired with the game's physics
system the monster kelp feels truly
unpredictable
and killer plants aren't the only threat
below the waves packs of giant
salamanders pursue the slug cat with
lethal determination able to hunt on the
land as well these amphibious Predators
share the long tongues of lizards and
seem to be a related species the only
defense the slug cat has is to swim with
all their might
for a quick boost of speed the slug head
can catch a ride by grabbing onto a jet
fish these fast-moving Aquatic Life
forms expelled Jets of liquid to create
large amounts of momentum which can be
used to rock it out of the water on land
jet fish aren't always the most graceful
but in the depths they make exploring
much easier
yet dive too deep and you'll find
monsters leviathans or among rain
world's largest and deadliest Predators
able to outpace and swallow a slug cat
in just a few seconds with their
powerful clamping Jaws seemingly a
mixture of metal and organic parts
leviathans are the first definitive
proof that not all life and Rain world
is naturally occurring
the beings who made the now ruined
structures of rain World a mysterious
group called the Ancients seem to have
disappeared long ago yet there is
another intelligent species that is
learned to pick through their Remains
the Scavengers these early tool Crafters
might have the most impressive AI across
all of rain World scavenger behavior is
insanely complex not just in terms of
how they interact with each other but in
terms of how they interact with you
though it's easy to miss scavengers
attempt to communicate with your
player's slug cat through a Litany of
distinct gestures if they think this
logcat is a threat they'll Point their
Spears at them if you move closer
they'll try and send a warning by
raising their Spears up if you persist
they won't hesitate to stick you full of
Spears but if you play it cool they'll
do the same all scavenger behaviors work
on a reputation system where they
remember the player's actions and
respond accordingly for example
sometimes you'll come across places
called tolls where scavengers won't let
you pass unless you trade them something
interesting and they even have a custom
animation to let you know you haven't
paid yet but if you do trade something
valuable like a pearl they'll sort of
wave you through letting you know you're
good trading gets more complicated with
Merchants specific scavengers that can
offer you unique technology when a
scavenger wants a specific item they'll
kind of paw at the ground or reach out
to the item to let the slug cat know
they'd like it and if you do give them
the item they'll drop something in
return like a lantern you can use to
light your way through the dark were
these blue orbs called flashbangs that
release a disorienting burst to Blind
enemies but if you take something from a
merchant without offering anything in
return they'll go on the offensive and
scavengers won't just mindlessly chase
after the slug cat and then give up if
you your reputation gets low enough they
will actively seek the player out even
sending hit squads to the slug cat's
General location it all comes together
to create encounters that at their best
feel like you're interacting with
something truly intelligent
with a scavenger Lantern in hand the
slug head explores the dark decrepit
wreckage of the Shaded Citadel another
ruin the Ancients Left Behind within the
Forgotten lower Pathways there's no
telling what awaits
the Monstrous wolf spiders Scurry
through the dark like most species in
the Shaded Citadel these spiders react
dynamically to light sources and will
generally avoid your Lantern but given
time hunger overcomes fear and where
there is one wolf spider there are
invariably others best to keep your
Lantern close
but not all the creatures in the Citadel
are quite so horrifying Lantern mice are
passive bioluminescent rodents that hang
from the ceiling with their long tails
in these shadowy Caverns they are a
welcome source of light Lantern mice are
notably skittish and will run in a panic
from the slug cat if they get too close
and Lantern mice have good reason to be
nervous skittering on countless legs or
the aggressive coalescipedes when they
go on the attack these disturbing
Predators resemble giant centipedes yet
in actuality they are made up of
numerous spiders that procedurally
combine into a chain when on the attack
because each spider is an independent
enemy AI getting swarmed feels all the
more overwhelming the best way to defeat
the coalescipedes is with the bright
light of a flashbang which stops the
scuttling terrors in their tracks
eventually the Shaded Citadel gives way
to The Bleak memory Crips patrolling
this region like nightmares centuries or
the shadowy miros Birds though difficult
to spot in the darkness these creatures
seem to be biomechanical with metallic
legs and scissor-like beaks flashbangs
are the only effective deterrent with
the bright light causing their eyes to
flash different colors allowing the slug
cat to sneak past
eventually you arrive at the underside
of a massive structure engulfed in a
green electrical storm entering the
structure the slug cat finds many rooms
like gravity due to localized disruptors
these zero gravity rooms can be
challenging to move through but the more
you see the more the entire
superstructure comes to resemble a giant
computer and at the heart of the
supercomputer a god-like artificial
intelligence is waiting this synthetic
life form is another creation of the
Ancients and possesses The Peculiar name
of five Pebbles using their incredible
power five Pebbles Alters the slug cat's
brain allowing them to understand the
Ancients language five Pebbles
dispassionately tells the slug cat that
a form of Ascension is waiting for them
if they keep heading west before turning
the gravity back on and sending you away
five Pebbles isn't the only one of these
AIS called iterators that the Ancients
created in a forgotten corner of the
shoreline the unusually named Looks To
The Moon wastes away if you speak to her
she'll explain that AI cannot Ascend in
the way the Ancients or the slug cat can
a limitation that has driven the
iterators that still function to despair
as the slow cat leaves the five Pebbles
supercomputer they need to sneak past
the gargantuan daddy longlegs these
oversized relatives of the brother
longlegs can hear the slug cat's
footsteps emitting blue rings of
particles when a noise is detected there
are hidden lore details that suggest
five Pebbles is actually the one who
created the long legs one of many
horribly failed attempts to fix a
decaying World behind the scenes of The
Long Legs AI each tentacle procedurally
searches for surfaces to latch onto
creating an unsettling yet strikingly
natural pattern of movement
continuing along the underside the slug
head bumps into the bizarre grappling
worms these small tubular creatures
suspend themselves from walls on sticky
pink appendages a treat the slug cat can
take advantage of by grabbing onto a
worm the slug cat can use them like a
living grappling hook to swing to new
areas
to make their way to the place of
Ascension the slug cat must climb a
massive exterior surface known simply as
the wall in this region has Perils of
its own pole plants or cleverly hidden
Predators which at a glance look like
any other Pole to be climbed on get too
close in the plant-like carnivore Will
Spring to life flaring at its red leaves
and dragging the slug cat into its den
to be devoured
continuing to climb the slug head is
ambushed by a skilled Predator known as
the drop wig which drags them back to
their Lair these insects resemble large
earwigs and are experts at catching prey
after finding a good hiding spot on the
ceiling the drop wig will place bait
like Spears beneath their perch to lure
prey into an ambush this behavior is an
intriguing display of intelligence and
makes the drop wig a cunning adversary
at last you reach the top of the wall
above the rain clouds for the first time
in the game it's a rare peaceful moment
elsewhere Atop The Wall the player's
slug cat encounters a spiritual remnant
of an ancient known as an echo which
tells you the Transcendence you're
looking for is close at hand the echo
says your struggles can all fade like a
Morning Mist beneath the glory of the
Sun by this point in the game The
Players face so many dangers that it
almost feels like the echo is speaking
directly to you
to reach your destination you must first
Brave the dizzying heights of the sky
islands flying centipedes called centa
Wings twist about in the atmosphere
undaunted by the formidable altitude
peculiar insects called noodle flies
also Buzz about in this region though
typically neutral when threatened they
extend a retractable needle-like tip
from their proboscis in attempt to spear
the slug cat clean through with noodle
flies around it is wise to move quickly
The Sky Islands lead to the expansive
Farm arrays the second to last ecosystem
before the end this biosphere is
dominated by worm grass hostile
plant-like creatures that attempt to
latch on and consume the slug cat when
it passes by the best way to cross large
fields of worm grass is to hitch a ride
on a reindeer these towering life forms
are the tallest land animals on rain
world and are able to step through the
carnivorous Fields thanks to their long
powerful legs since reindeer are one of
the few truly peaceful species you can
encounter there's something soothing
about their presence
at last the player's slug cat reaches
the dim dilapidated train tunnels of the
Subterranean ecosystem the final stop on
this great journey the region seems Grim
at first but eventually the air begins
to Glow with a mysterious golden Shimmer
in the shapes of ethereal sea life
glimmer in the dark some of these
environments are truly spectacular and
surreal with the game squeezing the
artistic power out of every last pixel
eventually the slug cat dives into a
vast sea of glowing liquid called void
fluid which the game hints is the same
substance that allowed the Ancients to
ascend in deep within this iridescent
environment a final creature is waiting
coiling in the infinite expanse the
unfathomably vast void worms spirals
within the fluid this creature is by far
the single largest life form in Rain
world and seems to call the inky black
abyss below the golden see its home an
unexpectedly inquisitive life form we
can get a glimpse of its surprisingly
small head when it comes to investigate
the slug cat whether or not the void
worm is the creator of the Void sea or
just an inhabitant is unknown for almost
everything about this Cosmic creature in
the Transcendence its home offers is
left a mystery
there's a lot of ways to interpret Reign
world's actual ending on the surface
level you swim into the light surrounded
by other slug cats or these members of
the family you lost at the beginning of
the game or the endless cycles of Trials
you've been through finally coming to a
close or is none of this even real in
the void sea the Ancients believed
offered Transcendence really just shows
you what it thinks you want you spend
the whole game trying to rise above the
ecosystem to break out of the food web
you find yourself in but is such a thing
really possible
I won't give away all my opinions on
rain world's ending because I think part
of the game's power comes from its
ability to be interpreted in any case I
certainly believe that rain World stands
out thanks to its incredibly unique and
detailed approach to simulating a
virtual biosphere through procedural
animation and AI interactions if you'd
like to check it out for yourself be
aware that it is a brutally challenging
game that really makes you feel like
you're on the bottom of the food chain
it's so dense that I couldn't cover
everything so there's lots more to
uncover if you'd like to take the plunge
yourself
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video